i've been using the airpods 3 for over a
month now so today i'm going to talk
about everything that i discovered along
with why i stopped using my airpods pro
and instead started using the airpods 3.
who would have thought that when apple
had courage to remove the headphone jack
in 2016 and right away gave us a
solution to the problems they created
that airpods would become a massive
company ranking in the top 30 beating
out both nvidia and amd's revenue
combined and almost reaching tesla's in
2020. people hated the idea of spending
159 dollars for wireless earbuds but
here we are years later and that price
seems like a bargain with the new
airpods 3 coming in at 180 bucks not far
off from what you can buy airpods pro
for this made it a really hard sell when
we first tested them but thankfully a
month later you can now pick him up for
150 bucks which we'll link to down in
the description
so after all of my testing are the
airpods 3 actually worth spending 150
bucks on let's talk about comfort these
things are extremely comfortable even
for somebody like me that doesn't have
any issues with the airpods pro i know
some people do some people just don't
like that sealed design and some people
simply can't use them which is why the
air pods original have been still very
popular now compared to those air pods
these do have a larger design i feel
like they fit more snugly into my ears
but they are not uncomfortable for me
for a select few people they might be a
little bit too large but in general
these things fit very nicely they do not
move and i think it is a much upgraded
design and because they don't seal into
your ear you get none of that plugged
feeling which is very very minimal on
the pros because of the vent that it has
but for this you just simply don't need
it and you don't have to use the ambient
mode or any software to be able to hear
your environment everything just leaks
in now there are two things that most
people don't talk about when they're
reviewing the airpods 3 that are
exclusive to these new earpods the first
one is a skin sensor that replaces the
optical sensor and this is great because
if you ever throw your air pods into
your pocket they won't automatically
turn on like the previous air pods and
the next one is the precision finding in
the app people lose airpods all the time
and with this feature it can actually
guide you to your ear pods just like if
it had an air tag even if they're in
their case which makes it a lot more
difficult to lose them compared to
airpods pro
now as far as battery life these are
also incredible and a really big step up
from the airpods too i was getting about
seven hours with just the buds
themselves and i thought that was a
little bit too high but i started doing
some research online and that is what
people are getting consistently so
that's about a 50 boost compared to the
airpods too and then with the case that
adds an additional four full charges and
that gives you roughly 35 hours of
battery life which is amazing compared
to most of their competitors
now probably the biggest issue with the
airpods 3 is the sound leakage these
things get quite loud and the open
design leaks a ton of sound i was
sitting in the room and i had him up
like maybe two thirds of the way and
redeem two computer stations down could
clearly hear all my music so if that's
something that matters to you definitely
take note that is something that is
greatly minimized with the pros or other
earbuds so if you're going to turn these
up and you're in a quiet room
everybody's going to hear what you're
listening to and that open design
without anything that actually goes into
your ear canal is probably one of the
biggest selling points and most of the
competitors they don't offer that almost
everybody makes earbuds that seal with a
silicone tip so apple is making sure
that they're still making this design
for the people that love it and overall
i get to say that i could wear these for
about two hours longer than i can with
the airpods pro and that is a big deal
now as far as sound quality these things
sound really good i love apple's new
sound signature and what they have done
it doesn't have as low bass as the
airpod pros because it's not a sealed
design but for mid bass they actually
play about three decibels louder which
is twice as loud while the mid-range is
a little bit toned down and then on the
high end the treble is also quite a bit
louder and the ultra highs are toned
down once again which gives it a more
natural sound and after over a month of
use i have to say that these are my
favorite airpods in terms of sound
quality apple's new drivers sound
fantastic and i really hope they release
pros that use the same technology
because the sound makes me pick these up
and use them instead of the airpod pros
i also love the apple integrated magnets
into this case so i just walk up to a
mac safe charging puck and it will
magnetize so i had one in the car i have
one at my desk here and at home and it's
just super convenient to be able to just
attach it now i do know that the new
airpod pros also have it if you get a
newer build
mine does not have that so it is one
additional convenience feature now
probably the biggest issue with these
it's not really an issue but it's a
downside is the lack of active noise
cancellation now over the last month
i've been doing a ton of stuff that
requires this so it hasn't been that big
of a deal but for certain cases where
for example i'm vacuuming or
i'm riding my lawnmower or mowing
that is actually one time where i do
want to pull out my airpods pro but
other than that if i'm using them
normally and a lot of times i like using
just one earbud inside my ear these work
a lot better for that and of course you
have the benefit of the better audio
quality so it's kind of up to you how
often you you are going to use active
noise cancellation and definitely
something that's very nice to have if
you're in a lot of noisy environments
that's probably the biggest selling
point that you still have to buy one of
these airpods pros has been around for a
couple years now if you're somebody that
spends a lot of time talking on the
phone for example phone calls or
anything else the microphones in here
are really good this is the microphone
quality with apple's airpods pro in a
normal room with some hvac noise and
this is the microphone quality with
apple's new airpods 3 in a regular room
that has some hvac noise they're
basically the same identical mics as the
airpods pros which are class leading so
people can't even tell that you're using
a pair of earbuds it sounds just like
you're actually holding up your phone so
there's not much to say there other than
it works really well
so overall after a month of use i have
found that i really enjoyed the airpods
3 i like the smaller case i like the
better battery life i like the sound
quality of it the sound signature that
sounds more natural you have more sound
stage or distinction
also between different instruments
overall this is the better product now
that they actually cut the price down to
150 bucks from the original 180 which
was a little bit too high even though
they already dropped it from 200 with
the airpods to the wireless charging
case i think this is a really good buy
unless you need active noise
cancellation and for those of you guys
out there that do want active noise
cancellation i would just say wait for
the air pods pro 2 because they're going
to get all the same improvements as
these maybe even better sound quality so
personally i'm very excited for those to
come out and after a month basically
what i found is that these are much
better earbuds than what people gave
them credit for when they came out
because not only is it just you know a
new design and basically the same thing
like some people were saying so thank
you guys for watching click that circle
above to subscribe check out one of the
great videos right over there that's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]